the result then which issues from this
antithesis consists in the fact that
consciousness drops like a discarded
cloak its idea of a good that exists
only in principle but has as yet no
actual existence in its conflict it is
learned by experience that the way of
the world is not as bad as it looked for
its reality is the reality of the
universal with this lesson in mind the
idea of bringing the good into existence
by means of the sacrifice of
individuality is abandoned for
individuality is precisely the actual
izing of what exists only in principle
and the perversion ceases to be regarded
as a perversion of the good for it is in
fact really the conversion of the good
as a mere end into an actual existence
the movement of individuality is the
reality of the universal
we arrived now at the last few
paragraphs of this section on virtue in
the way of the world and when looking at
paragraph 391 what we see is the very
beginning of the rehabilitation well not
the beginning but but an effectuation of
the rehabilitation of the way of the
world Hegel will say it's not as bad as
it looked as a matter of fact it's
actually quite good virtue has been
opposing the way of the world as if the
way of the world was bad but that's not
really the case so what what happens
here he says the result then which
issues from this antithesis this
opposition consists in the fact that
consciousness drops like a discarded
cloak the idea of a good that exists
only in principle now notice he's talked
about this cloak before right virtue was
caught up in the cloak as a fighter just
a few paragraphs earlier and couldn't
escape from it virtue could not escape
from the goodness of at least parts of
the way of the world that it was
supposed to be combating and changing
now consciousness is going to drop
virtue strapping the idea of a good that
exists only in principle but he has as
yet no actual existence now does that
mean that virtue never could have actual
existence no but at the time that it's
coming out it's really kind of a
promissory note isn't it and this is
something that is integral to modern
discussions of virtue even if we put the
word virtue aside and we talk about
goodness or fairness or justice because
Hegel is talking about something that is
supposed to be changing the world for
the benefit of humanity liberating
people from unfair you know and
self-replicating power structures all
these sorts of things that we could talk
about
we put aside the word virtue and we
substitute more contemporary language
Hegel saying well consciousness when it
realizes what's going on be doing that
and the way in the world
it ends up throwing whatever hasn't been
realized away and saying you're really
not any good you talk about goodness but
this is where I find the actual goodness
you know and again I mentioned teaching
in in prison last commentary video you
know when you're in a an environment
that is restricted like that it becomes
much more clear that you have to go with
realizable goods goods that you can
actually encounter and enjoy and
communicate to others not just some sort
of pie-in-the-sky thing that may never
really come about that's how people you
know if we want to go further with this
that's how people remain unliberated
chained oppressed exploited by reference
to these goods that are not actually
realized and and don't have some sort of
at least what we might call action plan
a explanation of how they're going to be
if we want to use business terminology
operationalized right that's quite
important Hegel goes on and he says in
its conflict the conflict between the
way of the world and virtue it is
learned by experience this is very
important it it can't just you you know
when you're doing the dialectic you
cannot just say oh well Hegel said that
this is the case so let's jump ahead
with that no sometimes we actually do
have to learn by experience now we can
learn by our own experience or we can
learn by the experience of others we
don't always have to learn everything
first
and ourselves but there are many things
that require learning by experience
that's what goes on in dialectical
phenomenology so he says it's learned by
experience with the way of the world is
not as bad as it looked for its reality
is the reality of the universal what
does that mean
what will the universal here is actually
individuality virtue had presented
itself as being the universal habit but
it turns out that virtue isn't the
universal or at least it's not the whole
of universal the way of the world
encompasses the universal so he goes on
and he says with this lesson what we've
learned in mind the idea of bringing the
good into existence by means of the
sacrifice of individuality is abandoned
the virtue was supposed to work and
overcome the way of the world by
sacrificing individuality the way of the
world
is that whole body of individuality
'he's that are in a bad state because
you know they follow out their own
selfish needs wishes inclination x'
desires and thereby make each other
miserable as a result and tie it you
know but they tie into power structures
and you know whatever we want to say
right so we don't actually have to
sacrifice individuality we don't to
offer it up if we want to you know play
on the german words you know of old fur
all right
he says individuality is precisely the
actual izing of what exists only in
principle this is really interesting
notice what he's saying here it's not
just that okay it's not a mantilla in
the sky
you know purely ideal good arrangement
for society you know some some sort of
map right and then say okay well let's
make that real over here individuals
matter for Hegel
this is not something that I think a lot
of people grasp when they're reading
Hegel individuality does matter
so he says individuality is precisely
the actual izing of what exists only in
principle and now here there's a little
bit bit of a play on words here that
Miller is engaging in that's not
actually there in the German the
perversion ceases to be regarded as a
perversion of the good for it is really
the conversion of the good as a mere end
into an actual existence
I wouldn't rest too much on that per
verses con thing because it's not
actually there in the german-soviet all
right so let's see what he's saying
though the perversion ceases to be retro
version of the good there is a turning
that's taking place right a purveyor
today there is a Orphic Arum right
something is being turned something is
being changed but it's no longer being
turned away from the good it's really
the conversion there the returning of
the good as a mere end into an actual
existence you know we we often think of
like the final good in Aristotelian
terms is like that's more important all
that Aristotle thought the final good
isn't just out there is like allure
drawing things it has to be realized or
it's not really a good right and Hegel
is saying the same thing here in this
section so he says the what do we have
here as a result the movement of
individuality is the reality of the
universal now how is that the case with
a look at the next paragraph for that
however with this result that which as
the way of the world stood opposed to
the consciousness of what existed only
in principle he has in fact likewise
been conquered and has vanished in that
antithesis individuality is being for
self as opposed to essence or the
universal and appeared as a reality
separated from what exists only in
itself or in principle but since reality
has shown itself to be an undivided
unity with the universal then just as
the in itself of virtue is merely an
aspect so does the being for self or the
way of the world also proved to be no
more than that the individuality of the
way of the world may well imagine that
it acts only for itself or in its own
interest it is better than it thanks for
its action is at the same time an
implicitly universal action when it acts
in its own interest it simply does not
know what it is doing and when it a vers
that everyone accidents his own interest
it is merely asserting that no one knows
what action is when it acts for itself
it simply gives reality to what to begin
with exists only in itself the purpose
of its being for self which it imagines
is opposed to what virtue is in itself
it's shallow cunning as also it's fine
spun explanations which know how to
demonstrate that the presence of
self-interest in that reaction all these
have vanished just as the purpose of
virtue that exists only in itself along
with its rhetoric have vanished
at this point in paragraph 392 what
Hegel is trying to do I mentioned a
rehabilitation of the way of the world
that is what he's carrying out but he
wants to show that the universal and
individuality wind up being connected
with each other or wind up in effect
being the way in which the universal is
able to have reality so he says with
this result that which as the way of the
world stood opposed to the consciousness
of what existed only in principle that
be virtue has in fact likewise been
conquered and has vanished in that
antithesis in the opposition
individuality is being for self the
selfishness the self-centeredness if you
like of the way of the world and the
individuals who are encompassed by that
individual out individuality is being
for self was opposed to essence or the
universal what was essence or the
universal at the very beginning it was
virtue
remember how virtue was so sure of
itself that it it was something batters
something higher something more powerful
than the way of the world why because it
subordinated individuality so he says in
that antithesis we had this opposition
and individuality is being for self
appeared as a reality separated from
what exists only in itself or in
principle and that is virtue
that's why virtue required that
self-abnegation that sacrifice that
offering of one's individuality the
individuality that otherwise would be in
the way of the world and you remember
what was caught in the balance were the
gifts and talents and capacities and
one's own choice right well we might
call one's will was in between now he
says but since reality has shown itself
to be in
undivided unity with the universal you
know the universal has the last laugh
the way of the world is that by which
it's communicated that last laugh right
so it's reality has shown itself to be
an undivided unity with universal just
as the in itself of virtue is merely an
aspect so does the being for itself of
the way of the world also proved to be
no more than that what we don't have
here is the way of the world simply you
know encompassing virtue and saying AHA
haha stupid virtue you thought you were
doing something new I managed to
encompass you within myself know both of
these are shown to be merely aspects of
something greater and what is that going
to be individuality individuality
understood not just as being this
individual but as being part of
something so he goes on and he says the
individuality of the way of the world
may well imagine that it acts only for
itself or in its own interest
now remember back to before we even got
into pleasure and necessity the
discussion of the ethical substance of a
people and how within that ethical
substance people act given their own
little horizons their own limited aims
they seem to be in conflict with other
people but it's all part of a larger
system we might call it a larger system
in which their selfish individual
self-centered short-sighted motivations
turn out to be part of a larger process
as Hegel said before the individual in
working for himself does not just work
himself he works for the rest of society
if this sounds like Adam Smith you know
that's along the same sort of lines
he's Hegel's not postulating an
invisible hand or anything like that but
he is saying that within in any
functioning you know organ organization
society the action that an individual
engages in is not just his or her own
action it becomes there by the action of
the whole and ends up doing more than
they intended so how does Hegel frame
this he says it doesn't know what it's
doing when it when it tells when it
averse that everyone acts in his own
interest what is it saying it doesn't
understand what action really is sure
people do in fact say to themselves
gotta look out for number one I'm gonna
do it I'm gonna do screw the rest of
them as a matter of fact if I have to
squash some of them so be it but some of
what they're doing is not just on their
own account it's spilling over into the
rest of the system because no person you
know is able to really have human action
entirely on their own we saw this in the
earlier section of observing reason as
well when we talked about all of that so
he says when it acts for itself it
simply gives reality to what to begin
with exists only in itself the purpose
of its being for self which it imagines
is opposed to what virtue is in itself
it's shallow cunning as odd as also it's
fine spun explanations which know how to
demonstrate the presence of
self-interest in every action if we look
at it properly Hegel says all of these
have vanished just as the purpose of
virtue that exists only in itself along
with its rhetoric have vanished so this
is an interesting ending point isn't it
we're finding that on the one hand the
individuality is connected with the
universality and on the other hand that
both
these turned out to be not the full
answer of what is going on or where the
individual should be taking his or her
cues from if he or she is to realize
what you know the whole goal of this was
their happiness their their purpose
their meaning the meaning of their
existence
thus the activity of individuality all
that it does is in its own self an end
the employment of its powers the play of
those powers in action is what gives
them life otherwise they would be a
lifeless in itself but the in itself is
not an unrealized abstract Universal
that lacks an existence but rather is
itself immediately the present real
existence of the process of
individuality
paragraph 393 is quite short but there's
a lot going on there that is is worth
dwelling on particularly given that it
is not just a rich section in its own
right but but it's also an endpoint it
is the end of this this section on
virtue in the way of the world we've
already seen that both virtue and the
way the world have turned out to be just
moments of something larger than it
which turned out to be the thing that
was caught in between the two of them
individuality right so we've got that
going on but it's also the end of this
entire section of actualization
self-consciousness this middle part
where we you know after we finished up
with with observing reason we moved to
this this other practical application of
reason and we start getting into things
that we would call the domain of the
ethical and start thinking about the
nature of society the things that we're
gonna see played out a lot more in the
sections yet to come particular than in
spirit section so what's going on here
Hegel as usual is bringing things to a
close but he's already preparing for the
section yet to come
and that section yet to come is this
this fairly short individuality which
takes itself to be real in and for
itself so by the end of this section we
should see individuality at least in
principle at least you know at the
beginning point of grasping itself as
real in and for itself I wouldn't worry
so much about the in and for itself
that's gonna get worked out later but
the real part is particularly important
here because remember what was the
problem with virtue what was the problem
also with the law of the heart it was
that it was not veer Clee
and in trying to make it external in
trying to make it real make you know if
we want to take a song title make it
real not fantasy right what had to
happen well this is where we we learned
what virtue at least modern virtue turns
out to be this is where we learn what
the law of the heart turns out to be how
they pan out neither one of them
measures up to their own self talk what
would Hegel is called a rhetoric in just
you know a few earlier passages so let's
now take a look at how he's going to
bring this section to a close this is
the activity of individuality all that
it does is in its own self and end now
the translation there is I'm usually
pretty happy with Miller that's not
quite that close right so the activity
of individuality the ton okay that's
action activity that that's great all
that it does is translating - alright
and kybun here it's a verb and it's
being used as a substantive just like
like - it is right there as opposed to
taht it's doing its driving right
private is to drive you know it's also
used for other things as well
but we could think about it as driving
itself it's it you know there's also an
idiomatic expression - and you know here
here as well what it does what what it's
occupying itself with its what it's
taking to be the focus and the locus of
its action we could say and that's okay
so that's okay now what does Hegel
saying here the activity of
individuality all that it does is in its
own self and end so I've kind of
misrepresented this here right
individuality is encompassed in the end
as much as in the activity and all that
it does but another way of doing this is
we can say well look this is also this
is also the the end we've encountered
this before where the activity itself
provides its own we might say imminence
right its own end within its own
activity not just an end way down the
line that we're aiming at a purpose an
end a focus you know an orientation of
goal but you know doing the activity
itself is in and this is this is what we
call Hegel's not mentioning this at this
point but this is kind of important
within the Aristotelian tradition this
is what we call praxis a term that the
Marxists are also going to use as well
and Aristotle uses this term as opposed
to another term which is poiesis making
or doing right as opposed the making or
doing that culminates in something else
right writing stuff here on the
chalkboard I'm not doing that just
because I like writing stuff on the
chalkboard I'm doing that for the end of
communicating information to you that's
the primary purpose so what I'm doing is
in some respect more poetic than praxis
oriented although praxis is also a part
of it as well now praxis means
activities where the end is encompassed
within the activity so for example you
know playing chess you know you could be
playing chess because you want to win a
lot of money probably not a great way to
try to win a lot of money unless you're
really good at chess you might be
playing chess to humiliate your opponent
because you want to impress somebody
else that you know autism make all these
stories up or you might be playing it
because you actually enjoy and find you
know meaningful the playing of chess and
then you're going to be playing it in a
different way that's that's praxis okay
so Hegel is saying here that individual
is now at the point where it's becoming
aware of what's going on with it now he
says the employment of its powers the
play of these powers in action is what
gives them life the use or the
employment of the powers the Dubrow dear
CAFTA what are the powers the the CAFTA
they are you know the talents the gifts
all the things that the individual has
at his or her disposal within him or
herself which which they might develop
further as well right that could be part
of the cabrillo they could pour how can
you know how they use those those powers
the play he says the play of these
powers in action if we want to be a
little bit closer spill their oyster
long and i seungyun the the the play of
their externalization the play of their
being made real that's what action is
really about the the actualization of
something he says the doing these things
with those powers is what gives them
life powers you know you could think
about powers and another word that we
use for that in philosophical terms is
potentialities right but again
potentialities if they remain mere
potentialities don't really matter
they're not Vaes and leaks they're not
important they're not essential they
become that by being made actual in a
world that we can look at and share and
do things in a world that you know
individuality exists in but an
individuality exists with other
individuality x' in some sort of
framework that's part of what we're
going to explore in the next section
also in the spirit massive section of
the text which is just you know
paragraphs away from us right now all of
this if we don't have this like he says
otherwise they would be a lifeless in
itself
you know we can talk about I have this
artistic talent you know well did you do
anything did you draw anything do you
paint anything to make any music did you
write anything no no man I'm I'm just
this artistic talent well no you're not
an artistic talent that you're just
somebody who likes to talk about art and
and maybe sitting around the coffee shop
or at the bar and talk about the great
stuff that you would otherwise be doing
but you're not really doing it it's
lifeless in itself so he says but the in
itself is not an unrealized abstract
Universal that lacks in existence now
that's if it's actually realized there's
plenty of in itself that are left behind
in in the dustbin of history that not
even in the history of history go on
right it says it's it's the in itself is
rather than is itself immediately the
present real existence of the process of
individuality individuality when it
actualizes
its powers when it works with them when
it does things when it engages in praxis
it becomes the universal in a certain
respect now that is a nice thing to
close on in part because you're probably
saying well what the hell does that mean
well that's what's going to be worked
out hopefully not entirely if I give you
a little spoiler not entirely but but
partially in the next section